well i was born in newark but i never
lived it to her my parents lived in
Maplewood New Jersey was just a suburb I
think the population is somewhere around
or it was at that time somewhere around
12,000 people maybe eight somewhere
between eight and twelve thousand people
you know houses were close together but
it was all the neighborhood's were very
nice and there was a lot of open space
there's a lot of parks babies that but
it was a great ease of going inside and
outside outside activities were very
much a part of one's life growing up
there something i always felt my
children who grew up in New York didn't
have that ease of going out to play
coming back inside going out meeting
friends freedom of movement just the
sort of idyllic environment as far as I
was concerned the age of 14 I remember
friends my parents coming from dinner
and they would say oh what do you want
to do when you grow up typical things
they say to a young teenager I said I
want to be an architect I'm not sure I
knew exactly what that meant at that
time but I decided that's what I wanted
to do and later I worked in the summer
as a carpenter's assistant on
construction jobs during the summer with
a friend of mine and then the following
summer I worked in an architect's office
where I swept the floors and went out
got coffee and did important things like
that
you